how was the big stage you wits in New
York yeah so what I did was I went to
New York and I originally went to meet
with some advertisers of ours and to be
wining and dining or what yeah yeah I'll
tell you about it and then I went to
being the Gary Vaynerchuk podcast and
then I went to be on
I didn't pop yeah everyone knows him as
pump Tom yeah and his podcast it was
cool did gary vaynerchuk's podcast first
thing in the morning at 8:00 or 9:00 or
10:00 a.m. when I got there I was a
little groggy from my flight because I
took some medicine when I flew it went
okay we'll see what happens so you walk
in what what happened yeah so walked in
so he has two offices in New York one
Hudson Yards which I've been to before
it's buzzing this one was a studio it's
a little quieter but still pretty badass
in Brooklyn Long Island City Long Island
City is it is which I don't know if
that's Brooklyn or not but it was
awesome man
and you guys know each other you don't
know each other so it's just like for
social I met but we had he knew who I
was and obviously I definitely know who
he is and he knew who our company was he
he was totally nice and he was really
low-key at first he wasn't like cocaine
Gary yeah he was like you guys do a
little chitchat small talk beforehand or
you just got into me so here's what
happened we sat down and there's like an
audience there was like an audience of
like ten maybe five or ten people me it
was me and Adam on our side of him he
had an entourage and we sit down and he
goes all right go
it looks at me and I was like I looked
at add up I go Gary I think you're
interviewing me he goes oh I am I was
like right Adam like is that right yeah
that's what we set up out of the safety
blanket yeah it was like oh okay so tell
me about who you are it was good it was
a nice guy that's good to know yeah you
know he's an easy target because he's so
loud yeah
I believe the screen went off there I
believe that he is totally legitimate
and a really good businessperson I think
his company Vayner is really really hard
to run and here
he was currently the CEO oh and CEO but
great business are being good business
and he's totally legitimate he's like
you can like what makes you say that so
long you could put him in like the
Donald Trump category of a guy who talks
a lot and you're like I don't know this
guy the real deal right he's totally the
real deal he just talks a lot but what
what were the little tidbits that gave
you that impression right cuz I believe
that I'm not saying you're lying
whatever I asked him ago so how do you
like working here I always ask employees
I ask the front desk I go what what's
what you know and you can kind of tell
if they actually like it yeah and when
he has 800 employees so the inn and the
office space was it was really expensive
real estate there was really nice
furniture everything was set up
professionally it's a real business
right so you could tell what's
legitimate and what is it once you go in
there in this Hudson Yards office they
had vaynermedia water bottled water the
office was buzzing everyone had nice
computers it wasn't it's not a start-up
right felt like a legit operation
totally for two hundred percent and
kudos to him man he's talented and you
did the podcast you know rate your
performance I gave myself a c-plus okay
and then because I was it was a I hadn't
done any reps that day like I did a
podcast later that day I had a Red Bull
firing yeah all right I'm on it it just
it just fell a little flat but Adam and
his people said it was one of their
favorite ones they've ever done and do
you have a little prep routine you would
do if but let's say before you get on
stage before you do an interview how do
you you know switch the light yeah well
I typically will like you know how it is
like when we're doing this thing I was
in a piss I was in a shitty mood a
minute ago and these lights turned on
and you're like I got a little like snap
out of it and what I do is I talk to the
receptionist or I'll talk to the uber
driver just to like start get out of
your hand get my words going and getting
a better happier mood yeah and that's
usually what I do okay is that what you
do no like everything I try to like
study and come up with like a framework
for how to do
like a technique and so I picked up two
things so I picked up one from Conor
McGregor that he I was watching this
documentary walk with the pencil in your
mouth pen in your mouth yeah so this I
tried it and it actually works fantastic
so basically you take a pencil or a pen
you hold it sort of horizontal sideways
you bite on it so it's in your mouth you
know sort of going out past your cheeks
and then you just talk for one minute
and what happens is because the pencils
they're in your mouths in this awkward
position your tongue has to really work
to like flick over and under this thing
to get to the spots it usually goes to
so you end up enunciated way better I
don't know if it's placebo I don't know
if it really is like an actual warm-up
for your tongue but this [__] works I've
recorded myself before and after and I
can tell the difference and other I had
other people listen to it I said Oh tell
me which one of these sounds better and
I don't know whether it's placebo or not
if that one works for me the other thing
is like a quick physical change so push
ups a wind spring jumping jack a scream
music whatever I am a big believer that
that that the fastest way to change the
way you feel is through changing your
body rapidly and Tans works that's like
a Tony Robbins ism Tony Robbins says
this great YouTube video if you go look
at if you're just YouTube young Tony
Robbins and it's you know the same guy -
25 years he's in a tank top and he's
given the speech and he talks about he
goes before I get onstage you know
people always ask me okay you're you're
public speaker you do you do a really
great job how do you do a great job of
this and he goes because I don't make
the mistakes most people do because most
people are sitting in a low energy shell
the body body posture sucks and then
they just get up on stage if they don't
warm up like an athlete would never do
that and he's like I treat myself like
an athlete I get myself in a mental
state a physical state and he goes the
second thing I do I don't try to
memorize what I'm supposed to say
because when you try to memorize what
you say you're trying to prepare well
what ends up happening is your mind is
then editing it's comparing what you're
saying versus what you kind didn't
remember you're supposed to say as you
give this other whole thing going on in
your head that takes you away from the
moment third thing and this is the last
one he goes before I go up there I
convinced myself that the audience has
to hear this like their lives depend on
this information like they me I'm here
to help and if I can get this across
like even with this podcast for example
it's like you know somebody is out there
they're commuting they're you know
they're they have this idea that they
haven't taken action on they're kind of
beating themselves up about it or you
know they look around at the five people
that they hang out with the most and
they're just like these people are not
like me and we're in their ear balls and
they're like oh there are people like me
out there and yes I should take some
action and yes I should have some
[__] energy today and so he's like I
just convinced myself that they have to
hear this and then I'm here to serve
them and I was like okay I do that just
doing that has made me feel better there
you go
another thing that I did while I was out
there is on Sunday night I tweeted out
so when I fly I take a lot of xanax it's
the only drug I do I don't do any
alcohol and sometimes the night before
I'll take it a little bit as well
because I really hate flying and so on
Sunday night I tweeted that I rented
this Airbnb which I did and I'm gonna
host a meet-up and I got 200 replies
saying let's meet up right and that I
couldn't do that so I only let 20 trend
subscribers come and so the trend
subscribers are also not 100 of you
listeners or not 100% and listeners are
subscribers but all subscribers are
listeners right and they so I met I
think at 30 ended up coming and it was
[__] awesome it was so cool this one
kid flew up from South Carolina or
something and I tweeted this on the
meetup was Monday night I tweeted this
on Sunday night yeah like there was no
preparation like we all we did me and
Adam landed and on Monday morning we
went to the Mexican place next door and
said hey can you bring over enough tacos
for 20 people there's two or three
hundred bucks and go buy some beer and
we'll pay you more money and that's all
we did and it was awesome
yeah these people are [__] fanatical
is crazy
it's nuts it's really odd who was the
most interesting person so many
interesting people one guy there was
this one guy I forget his name maybe
he's listening
he was an older the eldest guy there
which is not old but been his 50s or 40s
and he built was it builds custom logic
cards cars and through the trends groups
sold 50 cars just another custom
electric car yeah like I mean like he
was making uh like they took a take a
Prius or it took four no they took yeah
they took like a some type of pickup
truck and made it an electric delivery
van oh wow
for a cannabis company in LA cuz who
else did I mean I mean I met all types
of people one guy who sells fake boobs
for a living so he sells his he'll be
mower Fairchild he discover talk to you
on Twitter no child hunter yeah yeah I
see this guy on my Twitter all the time
yeah he sells fake boobs
yeah his boss invented like a better
dude what's in his bio cuz I've looked
at this guy's bio and he's not
advertising this this girl a DD we're
just sitting down a hunter came and we
were just shooting the [__] we're like
her what do you do and this woman a DD
she's nice I've met her before we were
just sitting there and she's like well I
sell breast implants and we were like
what and we just start talking I was
like so do you have like a woman who
comes with you and like shows you like
shows the buyers like you need like
sales brochures like how do you have
like how do you show that your boobs are
the best and he was just like walking
through this whole process it was crazy
I had never heard of such a thing yeah I
mean either but of course he came up
from Virginia for this that's great
alright cool so you can do more of that
of what well you and I need to do more
so what we can do is New York that we
could get I we could have gotten 200
people yeah so we can do one in New York
I think a cast or whatever we use tells
us where people are right we got to go
to Canada we got to go to Utah when we
shout it out Utah I know I still get
more the number of these friendly ass
Utah you know citizens whatever they're
called you tons reach out all the time
like hey when you guys are here I got
you
so maybe like and it feels good to be
taken care of like that does it feels
great maybe great hospitality
February yeah when you end of February
we should do a thing where we could try
to hit up like three cities in five days
right
[Music]